[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Tomiko Brown-Nagin, the
dean of the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study
here, at Harvard.
Welcome to the annual Kim
and Judy Davis Dean's Lecture
in the Social Sciences.
This year, featuring
Dr. Alondra Nelson,
president of the Social
Science Research Council
and professor of sociology
at Columbia University.
I'm delighted to have
Alondra here with us today,
and thrilled that all of
us have the opportunity
to hear from her.
Let me extend a special welcome
to Kim Davis and members
of the Radcliffe Institute
Leadership Society,
as well as our generous
annual donors, who
make the work of the
Institute possible.
Thank you for your support
Alondra Nelson is
an acclaimed scholar
and distinguished
leader both in academia
and in the world of policy.
She's also a respected
public intellectual,
who frequently devotes
her intellectual firepower
to advancing racial
and social justice.
Alondra pushes her
fellow social scientists
to be similarly engaged with the
world, encouraging researchers,
to quote Alondra, "ask
the hard questions
about the public good.
Reach new audiences,
and communicate
effectively and emphatically."
Alondra's own scholarly work
in women and gender studies,
as well as
African-American studies,
sits at the intersection of
science, technology, medicine,
and inequality.
She investigates
how science shapes
the world we inhabit, exploring
questions of identity,
collective action,
and our engagement
with scientific
conceptualizations of race,
ethnicity, gender,
and much more.
Alondra's latest
book, The Social Life
of DNA, Race, Reparations,
and Reconciliation
After the Genome, results
from a decade plus
of ethnographic research
on direct to consumer
genetic ancestry testing.
Beginning in the early 2000s,
long before ancestry tests
became mainstream, let alone
advertised as holiday gifts,
Alondra set out to learn
why people take them
and what they might
tell us about who we are
and who others think we are.
In particular, she wondered
why African-Americans
were among the earliest
adopters of this new technology.
The Social Life of
DNA explains how
individual genetic
information gathered
from take-at-home tests became
a socio-political catalyst.
Newly accessible genetic
data have not only
been used for ancestral
roots seeking, but also
to expose aspects
of societal amnesia
around American slavery.
Some African-Americans turned
to the test to reckon with,
to quote Alondra, "the
unfinished business of slavery
and its lasting shadows
of racial discrimination
and economic inequality."
Yet, as she cautions, "DNA
can offer an avenue towards
recognition but cannot
stand in for reconciliation,
which encompasses voice,
acknowledgment, mourning,
forgiveness, and healing."
Alondra's earlier
award winning book,
titled Body and Soul, the Black
Panther Party and the Fight
Against Medical Discrimination,
examines a related set
of issues through the lens
of the little known health
activism of the Black Panthers.
In Body And Soul, Alondra
tells the fascinating history
of the Black Panthers'
community clinics,
including the country's first
grassroots genetic screening
program, which was set up to
test for sickle cell anemia.
Currently, Alondra is
at work on a new book
on science and technology policy
in the Obama Administration.
And it is the subject
of her talk today.
Alondra began her teaching
career at Yale University
after earning a PhD
in American Studies
from New York University.
Since 2009, she's
been on the faculty
at Columbia, where
she's also served
as director of the Institute
for Research on Women, Gender,
and Sexuality.
Inaugural dean of social
science and founding
co-chair of the Precision
Medicine and Society Program,
she also spearheaded Columbia
University's participation
in the Obama Administration's
collaborative to advance equity
through research.
Today, as president of the
Social Science Research
Council, Alondra leads national
and international efforts
to advance research
for the public good
and works to mobilize
scholarship and resources
to tackle pressing questions
with implications for policy,
equity, science, and much more.
It's hard to imagine a better
person for this critical work
and for today's lecture.
And now, please join me in
welcoming Alondra Nelson
to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you so much,
Dean Brown-Nagin, again,
for that incredibly
generous introduction.
And special greetings
to a few people.
I was so happy to have so
many dear friends here.
I want to thank, as
I begin, Kim Davis.
I'm delighted to be here
under the auspices of the Kim
and Judy Davis Dean's Lecture.
I want to send special greetings
to Daniel Carpenter, who
I know plays a special role here
at the Radcliffe in the Social
Sciences.
And I have to say, those of
you who study bureaucracy
or the state, as I am trying
to do for the very first time,
we would be completely
lost without Daniel
and without his work on the FDA
and other regulatory capture
and the like.
Greetings to Marina
Whitman, who is
a member of the SSRC
advisory board visiting
committee, who's here and,
I think, a Radcliffe alum.
And also to two of the
most important mentors
in my life, Evelyn Hammonds
and Patricia Williams,
who I'm delighted to see
and who have supported me,
quite literally, for decades.
I think I wouldn't have tenure
without either of them, truth
be told.
So I've been busy doing
administrative work.
But I think one must
always do our research.
It's the thing that brings
us to graduate school.
It's the questions that
we have about the world.
So I'm working at a more glacial
pace than would be desired.
But I am working,
nonetheless, and have
been spending about the
last year and a half
talking to staffers in
the Obama Administration,
starting mostly with
junior staffers who
worked, many of them,
across the whole eight
years of the administration,
and continuing forward.
So I'm going to
tell you a story--
I think that'll be a wistful
story for some of you--
about the recent past and
give you some ideas about--
it's too soon to, I think,
make any proclamations
about the legacy of the
Obama Administration.
But I just want to
make some gestures
about what I think
was particularly
important with regards to
that administration's work
with science and technology.
So I told you it'd
be a little wistful.
Here are two images.
One of the very
first magazine covers
of the Obama era, Paging
Dr. Obama, obviously,
a Time cover about the
Affordable Care Act
and all of the controversy
and political debate
that would come with it.
And his very last cover
from Popular Science,
in which he did an
interview summing up
his work in the administration,
in particular, talking
about science.
So in that arc, from the
beginning to the end,
it's easy to gather
data, if one looks,
about how this was
probably one of the most
extraordinary experiments in
federal science and technology
policy.
And I'm going to offer you
a few data points, to begin,
for why that's the case.
But my talk will
really be about what
is a hidden facet of this
work, the ethical framing
that I think is important.
So this is Obama pictured
with his science advisor, John
Holdren, your colleague here.
And it's really probably not
since the influential tenure
of Vannevar Bush in the US
Office of Scientific Research
and Development in
the mid 20th century,
during President Franklin
Roosevelt's tenure,
that science had played
such a powerful role
in a presidential
administration.
So Holdren was not only director
of the Obama Office of Science
and Technology Policy, he
held two other hats besides.
He was co-chair of the
Presidential Council on Science
and Technology,
PCAST, in addition to
being OSTP director, and led
a national council, as well.
So it's little clear to see
here than it is on my screen.
So this is the configuration
of the Obama Science OSTP.
Holdren held the
top three roles--
OSTP director.
He was a co-chair of the
President's Council of Advisors
on Science and Technology,
or PCAST, as well as
the Chair of the National
Science and Technology Council.
So in other administrations,
different people
had held all of these roles.
Holdren held them
simultaneously.
You'll also see that
the OSTP built out
lots of different work
that included the STEM
fields, energy science,
climate science, cybersecurity,
and the like.
And a phrase that came up often
in folks that I talked to,
who worked in the OSTP, was
that science touches everything.
So this was a kind of
ethos of the Obama OSTP.
Part of the reason why Holdren
and other people working
in the administration
would be dual hatted
or tri-hatted it in their
positions in the administration
was because they felt
like there needed
to be an expansive and
capacious way to how they
thought about doing their work.
So PCAST, this
Presidential Council
of Advisors on Science
and Technology,
were external advisors.
These included folks like
Eric Schmidt of Alphabet,
Rick Levin, then president of
Yale who went on to Coursera.
And you can see
that in their work,
they did some of the work that
gave framing and shape to some
of the important initiatives
of the Obama Office of Science
and Technology Policy.
So big data, K to 12 STEM
education, health care,
and health care information,
data informatics, and the like.
So Holdren would
co-chair this entity
with Eric Lander
and Harold Varmus.
More generally, the
Obama Administration
appointed many
prominent scientists
to his administration
and to advisory boards,
including five Nobel
laureates and 28 members
of the National Academies
of Sciences, Engineering,
and Medicine.
Moreover, this PCAST
was more active than any
of their predecessor
bodies in the three
prior presidential
administrations.
So they, over eight years,
published 36 publications,
like these here.
By comparison,
there were about 12
in the former W.
Bush Administration.
There were 46 meetings
over eight years.
By comparison, there were 30,
21, and 20 in the prior three
administrations.
And for the first
time, members of PCAST
were given security clearances.
So they could offer
advice to the president
and his administration
on cybersecurity
and other important,
sensitive issues.
So this was one facet of the
way that the Obama science
apparatus-- the way
federal science under Obama
was distinctive in the way
that it was put together.
Also distinctive was that
over the course of the eight
years of his presidency, Obama
published 13 journal articles.
Many of these were
advocacy articles.
They're not putting
us all to shame.
They were commentaries.
So Harvard Law Review,
New England Journal
of Medicine, Journal of the
American Medical Association,
Nature and Science,
just to name a few.
So these are just
examples from late
in his administration,
where he's
trying to make the case
for all that they did.
He's tired.
He's saying these are all
the things that we did,
including, notably, the
commentary from the Harvard Law
Review on criminal justice
and the important work
that his OSTP would do
around forensic science.
This would be the
last paper that he
would publish in Science, making
the case for energy policy,
certainly in the weeks
before the Paris Climate
Accord would fall apart.
Then there was the euphoria
of the Obama Administration.
That was also distinctive.
So he brought to the White House
for the first time the White
House Science Fairs.
They ran to really
celebrate the winners
of local and regional STEM
and science competitions
in K to 12.
And they ran from 2010 to 2017.
And they, since, are
no longer going strong.
So here's young Obama
with not so much gray hair
with a young boy
with a projectile.
Older Obama holding a model
of a flu bug in his hand
at one of the later
science fairs.
So he would inaugurate
them working
with a gentleman named Kumar
Garg, who worked for eight
years in the Obama OSTP.
And this would be
distinctive, as well.
So we got a sense of how
distinctive the Obama
approach to science was.
Because with the establishment
of the Trump Administration,
it became very clear.
So just to think about
the staffers in the OSTP,
at its height, there
were 143 staffers.
And when the Trump
Administration
was established and
came to the White House,
there were about 30 staffers.
And I think now,
there are about 40.
So it also gives you a scale
of the investment and staffing.
What I want to suggest
to you this afternoon
is that there's a less
obvious impact, or influence,
or something distinctive
about the Obama OSTP,
and this particular federal
approach to science,
which was a kind
of ethical framing.
So I'm taking this up as
a way to frame a larger
project, which is a book project
that will be about moonshots.
I'm working on moonshots in
the Obama Administration.
That will include the BRAIN
Initiative, white papers
and initiatives on Big Data and
AI, the first national Nudge
unit, Social and
Behavioral Research Team,
taking place in the White House.
Precision Medicine, which
I'll talk about today,
and the Cancer Moonshot.
And in discussing
this, as I said,
I'll draw on some of the
interviews I conducted,
as well as content analysis,
my own experience, and one
of the ethical framing
performances of the Big
Data and AI, as well as
quite a few of Obama's
speeches, as you'll see in
his own presentation of self
with regards to
ethics in science.
So the moonshot,
of course, comes
from a famous speech at Rice
University in Houston, Texas,
September, 1962.
John F. Kennedy
ascended a podium
in front of a large crowd
gathered at a stadium, at Rice.
And he really made
the case for the goal
of sending rockets and
men to the moon, the goal
of technological innovation,
and the aspiration
to use federal funding
and federal human capital
to do this in a limited
time frame of two years.
He says "but why,
some say, the moon?
Why climb the highest mountain?
We choose to go to the
moon in this decade,
not because it will be easy,
but because it will be hard."
The moonshot, of course,
has been taken up
in other parlance.
Of course, one of the Obama big
initiatives launched in 2016
with Vice President Joe Biden
leading it is a $1.8 billion
investment in cancer research,
called the Cancer Moonshot.
It's also the case that
the moonshot, today,
is understood as being any
kind of ambitious project.
The moonshot is used
to talk about what
was called Google X, now
X, an incubator project
for innovative science
and technology.
But it should be noted here that
the Google Moonshot are really
about a problem to a project
to design to a particular kind
of outcome.
That makes them a
little bit different
from the federally funded ones.
So I want to suggest to you
that throughout the course
of this administration, and
even in his time as senator,
that President Obama very
much understood, I think,
two things.
And we see them as
well in his memoir.
Sort of the sense
that science was
going to be important to his
administration, for reasons
that I will say a
little bit more about.
But I think in his person
and also in his presentation
of self, as I said, it
was very important for him
to always give voice to the
ways in which science had failed
and had been used
for pernicious ways.
So this is him from
a speech in 2016.
He's the first sitting
president to visit Hiroshima,
notably not to make an
apology, but to give a speech.
In this speech, he says,
"technological progress
without an equivalent
progress in human institutions
can doom us.
The scientific revolution that
led to the splitting of an atom
requires a moral
revolution, as well."
Early in his administration,
you may recall,
he was asked to
be a commencement
speaker at Notre Dame.
And it was highly
controversial, because he
was an explicitly pro-life
candidate and also
a candidate who was
committed to advancing,
to a limited degree,
stem cell research, which
was a contrast with the prior
administration of George W.
Bush.
So part of what he says
in his speech that day,
in May of 2009, is "let us be
sure that all of our health
care policies are grounded
not only in sound science
but also in clear ethics."
So I want to demonstrate
today that the sort
of ethical terrain that Obama
and his administration endeavor
to work around and through
is dealing with the past
and really having to
reckon with the past.
They have to overcome
citizen skepticism related
to the history of
experimental abuse.
They have to establish
ethical regulations, in part,
so new science, new
moonshots can go forward.
And they have to
generate a perception
of ethical forethought.
That the moonshots that
they are proceeding with
have been thought about, that
these are considered moves.
And in this way, they are
distinctive from someone
like Vannevar Bush, who
I mentioned earlier.
In the historical archive,
in the secondary literature
about Bush and about
the Manhattan Project
and the formation of what
would become the atom bomb,
there are, I think,
poignant reflections
on this from folks
like Oppenheimer,
only a few years later.
What was striking to me about
the historical record on Bush
is that there was never a
sense in his conversations
and in his work,
and certainly, not
in this masterful biography
from Pascal Zachary,
that they thought they
should had to ask anybody.
That there was any
sense of accountability
on the part of Bush,
although it might have not
been true of others on the
Manhattan Project team,
that there was anyone that had
to be engaged in this process.
And moreover, in some
cases in the biography,
Zachary writes about Bush
being asked whether or not
there should be any kind
of what we might call
today ethical engagement
or conversation about
whether or not
this would proceed,
and found it
utterly unnecessary.
So part of what we're seeing
here, I want to suggest,
is the creation and
extension of an ethical frame
that a few decades
prior, and certainly
a few presidential
administrations prior,
did not exist.
And I'm going to
track this for you
in a few ways, this afternoon.
First, beginning with the
formation of the ELSI Program
that emerges alongside the
Human Genome Project in 1990.
So the Human Genome
Project begins.
And soon after, there
is a working group
that would become a project
on the ethical, legal,
and social implications
of that project.
Its original mandate included
identifying and defining
issues that were related to the
Human Genome Project, policies
for addressing
them, with 3% to 5%
of the annual Human
Genome Project budget.
And this has been
discussed in some quarters
as the largest ethics
project in human history.
So I want to bring
to our attention
that initially,
the ELSI project--
the Ethical, Legal,
and Social Implications
of the Human Genome Project--
was actually quite
broad and capacious.
That it covered a
lot of territory
that it would not
cover in the end,
highlighting a little bit
here, for you Privacy and fair
use of genetic
information with respect
to employers and insurers, but
also direct marketers, banks,
credit raters, law enforcement
agencies, and many others.
The availability of large
amounts of genetic information
and largely
unprotected databanks,
possible discriminatory
misuse of genetic information,
and the fact that the use
of genetic information
and genetic screening could
exacerbate the creation
of a genetic underclass.
But by 1991, the scope of ELSI
is significantly narrowed.
So the issues here are
privacy and fair use
of personal genetic information,
genetics in the workplace,
and genetic education.
So you continue to see articles
like this in the Human Genome
News, which was the official
newsletter of the project.
But what we might call the more
radical interpretations of what
ELSI might have
been, and its ability
to not only be downstream,
as critics of ELSI
would come to say,
but also anticipatory
in thinking about how
genetic data might be used
in the marketplace, for
example, for purposes of bias
and discrimination are shaved
off of the scope of this work.
So even though the work narrows
from this initial mission,
from this to this,
it also expands.
So by the early
aughts, ELSI has gone
from being a project
that runs in parallel,
an ethical analog to the
Human Genome Project,
to also being part
of a conversation
about nanotechnology.
So it's expanding from
the Human Genome Project
to nanotechnology.
Paul Rabanow and Gaiman
Bennett, in 2012,
publish a fascinating, poetic,
sometimes confusing book--
but a very interesting
book on their engagement
and trying to be an ELSI
partner for synthetic biology
as it's emerging,
a few years later,
in the early 20th century.
So what we can track
if we follow even
the narrow ELSI is
a sort of expansion
of an ELSI frame from
the Human Genome Project
to nanotech synthetic
biology and other forms.
So those of you who work
in the life sciences
know that there's pretty
much the ELSI of everything.
Any project that you
do can and often must,
depending on who's funding
it, have an ELSI component.
And I want to argue
that by the time
we get to the Obama
administration,
there's been a full
sail ethical turn,
such that to do federal
science means to be expected
to have some forms
of accountability
and to be able to at
least perform answers
to certain questions about
the implications of moonshots.
So ELSI is one
origin or one pillar
of why I think this
ethical framing comes
to be prominent in the
Obama administration.
And another is
the administration
that preceded it.
So here's Obama pictured
again with John Holdren.
Holdren, whom he appoints
before he becomes president-- so
to give you a comparison,
George W. Bush
didn't nominate and then have
appointed his first director
of the Office of Science
and Technology Policy
until almost a year
into the administration.
And we know, of course,
that President Trump did not
nominate someone until well a
year into his administration.
So it was really uncommon
for someone to be nominated
before a new president
even takes office.
And it's certainly
the case that, as I
said, early in his
administration, indeed,
here in his inaugural
address, Obama
places front and center his
commitment to restoring science
to its rightful place
in his administration.
Part of what that
meant was a reaction
to what they understood
Obama and many of his science
advisors to have been--
a politicized
bioethics that emerged
by conservative ideologues
during the Bush administration.
For them, that was really summed
up in the case of Terry Shiavo.
You'll see on her
gravestone, here,
that was commissioned
by her husband.
She departed this earth
on February 25, 1990,
and was at peace in March, 2005.
So between 1990 and
2005, of course,
there is a contest
between her husband, who
said that to abide
by her wishes would
be to allow her to depart
this earth in February,
1990, and her parents, who
insisted on keeping her
in a vegetative state.
And then all around, a
raging public discourse
about the right to
life and the way
in which this
controversy was abducted
into that conversation.
So as a senator,
Senator Obama is already
engaged in trying
to think about how
to think about the relationship
between religion and science
or religion and reason.
This is a speech that he gives
in 2006, in Washington DC,
in an ecumenical
religious forum.
He says, "I do not believe
that religious people have
a monopoly on morality.
I would rather have someone
who is grounded in morality
and ethics, and who is also
secular, affirm their morality,
and ethics, and values without
pretending they're something
that they're not."
So part of a group of people, a
group scholars-- bioethicists,
in particular--
galvanize around a project that
they call Science Progress.
And some of them
would personally
identify in
contradistinction to those
who were the bioethicists,
who understood themselves
to be conservative, as
progressive bioethicists.
So two exhibits, A and
B, from that time period
are these books edited
by Jonathan Marino,
a prominent
bioethicist who teaches
at the University of
Pennsylvania, at present.
But at the time, he was a
senior fellow and the founder
of the Science Progress
Project at the Center
for American Progress.
And here, you see the
kind of ELSI frame
and a bioethics frame expanding
broadly just in these two
edited collections.
So you have more than
the life sciences, here.
They're talking about progress
in bioethics and ethics frames
around electronic medical
records, solar energy,
broadband, neuroscience, and
organizational innovation.
So the expansion of
this ethical framing
is happening here,
among other places.
The Science Progress Project was
launched under the presidency
of John Podesta, who
had been chief of staff
under the Clinton
Administration,
and was allowing these
bioethicists to galvanize
and create programming and
strategy around what they would
want to do when the
administration of George W.
Bush and the conservative
bioethicists who were advising
him would move on.
So what's interesting
here are, I
think, claims that are
not always associated
with the left.
So Science Progress
understood that coming out
of the era of social movements
of the '60s and '70s,
that science had to
be participatory.
That it was
inherently political.
It was a project of progressive
science policy, as I said.
And they also
understood or wanted
to assert that one could
combine ethics and innovation
and ethics and reason, and
that these things were not
diametrically opposed.
And this was part
of the particularly
progressive framing that
they wanted to advance.
So I should say that Marino,
the co-editor of both
of these volumes, the leader
of the Science Progress
Project at the Center
for American Progress,
would be a member of
Obama's transition team
from 2008 to 2009.
John Podesta, who played a
role here, as well, by 2014,
is working in the
Obama White House
and is working on many
of the moonshot launches,
including the launches of
the AI and Big Data projects
that happen around that time.
So as I mentioned,
it's also the case
that Senator Obama
was engaged in issues
around genetics and ethics.
So in 2006 and also
in 2007, he introduces
with Republican Senator
Richard Burr of North Carolina
the Genomics and
Personalized Medicine Act
both of 2006 and 2007.
And versions of
this act would be
introduced by other legislators
after Obama entered the White
House.
But this was very much front
and center for him and his time,
in his few years in the Senate.
So what this act endeavored
to, in its words,
"improve access
to and utilization
of valid, reliable
genetic tests,
and to secure the
promise of personalized
medicine for all Americans."
So while neither
President Obama's bill
nor the subsequent versions
from him and other legislators
were ever enacted,
much of what was here
was ultimately incorporated
into the 21st Century Cures
Act that was signed by President
Obama, in December of 2016,
towards the end
of his presidency.
In this 21st Century
Cures Act, some of you
might know, include not
only the $1.8 billion
for the Cancer Moonshot
that I mentioned,
but also $1.5 billion
for precision medicine,
for its infrastructure, and
for the larger project of it.
Notably, Obama would note
that it was important to him
that ethical
guardrails were placed
around the issue of
personalized medicine
before it could move forward.
So here is a report
from the GINA Act,
which I'll say a little bit more
about-- the Genetic Information
Nondiscrimination Act of 2008.
And his reaction to it,
according to a staffer,
was that Obama
said that he wanted
to do the genomics bill,
this act of 2006 and 2007.
But that he didn't
want to go anywhere
with it until GINA passes.
Sort of the sense
that we had to have
some sort of protective
regulations in place before one
could move forward.
So the GINA Act, of
course, in short,
was signed into
law by George Bush
and enacted in November, 2009.
It protects against the
use of genetic information
to discriminate in the
provision of health care
and also with regards
to employment.
So moving forward
to January, 2015,
when President Obama, in the
State of the Union address,
would announce a $215
million investment.
Later, by 2016, as I've just
mentioned, in this 21st Century
Cures Act, the total investment
would be $1.5 billion
to launch this
Precision Medicine Act.
So he said, "tonight, I'm
launching a new Precision
Medicine Initiative to bring
us closer to curing diseases
like cancer and diabetes."
And I want to also
highlight this second part.
"And to give us all access to
the personalized information
we need to keep ourselves
and our families healthier."
So on the one hand is
research investment.
On the other hand, a recognition
that will become clearer as I
go on about the role
that he's trying
to create for the individual,
citizen, consumer,
patient in a Precision
Medicine Initiative.
So in brief, the Precision
Medicine Initiative
is a research endeavor
that aims to understand
how a person's genetics,
environment, and lifestyle can
help to determine the best
approach to prevent or treat
disease.
Short term goals,
as announced by NIH,
include expanding
precision medicine
in the area of cancer
research and to increase
knowledge of genetics and
the biology of cancer.
A long term goal, bringing
precision medicine
to all areas of health and
health care on a large scale.
But all of this faced
some of the hurdles
that I mentioned, previously.
So just to repeat
these, they needed
to overcome citizen
skepticism related
to the history of
experimental abuse.
They needed to establish
some ethical regulations.
And the GINA Act of 2008 was
a first step in doing this.
And also to generate
a perception
of ethical forethought.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about one and three, now.
So Obama announces
on January 15, 2015,
in the State of the Union
address, the Precision Medicine
Initiative.
And about two weeks later,
he has a launch event
in the east room
of the White House.
And here, you see one of the
things he does again and again,
which hearkens back to, some
ways more or less explicitly,
a history of abuse.
That would give
people misgivings
about precision medicine.
And tries to encourage people
that they should move forward.
So he says here at this launch,
"we've got to figure out,
how do we make sure that if I
donate my data to this big pool
that it's not going
to be misused?
That it's not going to be
commercialized in some way
I don't know about?
And so we've got to set up
a series of structures."
So part of the
structures was a series.
This is a fascinating
document on privacy and trust
principles.
At its most radical,
it's asserting a right
to citizen science, a right
for individual consumers
to be able to use their
genome, and to have access
to the information that
their genetic information
and genetic data might provide.
It asserts a strong
right to privacy.
It asserts a 21st
century version
of a patients' bill of
rights or research subjects'
bill of rights.
It's a very
aspirational document.
And indeed, it's a document
about any legal bearings.
So it's kind of all aspiration.
But it's a very interesting
historical document
that, I think, we'll be
talking about for a long time.
Because it very much
bears the imprimatur,
I think, in some ways, of many
of the kind of Silicon Valley
diaspora that come to work in
the Obama administration, that
take pay cuts, who very much
believe in the work that's
being done here to advance
science and technology policy.
And bring with them a very
kind of romantic idea of what
science and technology can do.
Another quote from Obama that
gets him in trouble, "I would
like to think that if someone
does a test on me or my genes,
that that's mine.
But that's not always how
we define these issues.
So there's some legal
issues involved, as well."
So within a few hours,
The New York Times
is talking about how
the president weighs
in on data from genes.
Because as many of us
know, your genomic data
does not belong to you.
Someone captures
it in a laboratory.
And indeed, George
Contreras, who's
a law professor at the
University of Utah,
who I interviewed recently, who
went to law school with Obama,
here at HLS, writes this
rejoinder to President Obama.
That says in part, "US
courts have repeatedly
denied individual censorship
claims over data derived
from their cells and tissue.
Just imagine the
chaos that would
ensue if each of the million
participants in the Precision
Medicine Initiative
could claim ownership
over discoveries that were
made after large pools of DNA
were analyzed."
So imagine, indeed.
So President Obama
and his staff realized
that they had to, for all
sorts of reasons, sell it.
So this is, as
far as I can tell,
the only of their big projects
that had two launches.
So there's the
January 2015 launch.
That's a couple of weeks after
the State of the Union address,
in which Obama launches this.
Then there's a
summit a year later.
Which he engages
researchers, the woman here,
from the Broad Institute,
research scientists
to talk about, in a public way--
this was streamed-- what the
Precision Medicine Initiative
might be able to accomplish.
But also to give voice
from the perspective
of patients, consumers,
health care economists--
what some of the
challenges might be.
So there's lots of conversation,
most of it initiated
by him about
privacy fears, about
fears of genetic
discrimination, about
the need for new safeguards,
and also the need
for more nimble
regulation if something
like precision medicine should
take off in the United States.
Actually, I think
this is fascinating.
It's 42 minutes.
It's really interesting,
because President Obama
is on the stage with
actual scientists
and takes it upon himself
to talk about the science.
So there's also this odd--
as someone who really admires
expertise, as he does,
he's also very learned
and very much wanted
to demonstrate that
he had learned quite
a lot about genome wide
association studies,
and the need for
diverse databases,
and all these sorts of things.
So it's a fascinating
performance
of the ethical framing
that I'm talking about.
And also, it's an interesting
Obama presidency moment.
So part of what they're talking
about in this conversation
is anticipation of a facet
of the Precision Medicine
Initiative called All of
Us, which is an endeavor
to recruit 1 million volunteers
from around the United States
to provide genetic data,
biological samples,
and other health information.
Because the genetic data is not
useful without the other health
information.
And also to encourage
open data sharing.
So there's this open
science, citizen science
piece of this that remains.
Volunteers will
be able to access
their health information
as well as research
that uses their data.
So as President Obama would
suggest in this conversation,
this summit at
which, again, they're
really trying to sell people.
And they're trying to
get people to overcome
their skepticism,
variously, about why
this should go forward.
So they're really selling
it at this second summit.
It's important that these
be, as he describes,
diverse databases.
And so the face
of all of us often
looks something like this.
We need a million person
database that, quite frankly,
is probably over sampled
for people of color,
if the sort of types of
big data analysis that
wants to be accomplished
can be accomplished, there.
And this remains
a central issue.
This is an article that a
colleague, Maleeha Fullerton,
published with a
colleague in Nature,
called Genomics is
Failing on Diversity,
about the lack of diversity
in genetic databases.
That really gave a sense
of urgency to the All of Us
initiative.
If it's the case that we need
to have more diverse databases,
how are we going to get there?
This is data from
the same article
about the bias, with
regards to genetic samples
that they're significantly
majority genetic samples
of European ancestry,
that have, obviously,
analytic implications for
the import of the work
if precision medicine works,
and if this Precision Medicine
Initiative is to go forward.
So there's a kind
of fever to get
these more diverse databases.
It's also part of
the express mission
of the All of Us Initiative.
But all of this is
occurring against a backdrop
in which other things
with data are happening.
So Nancy Secola, in the
Wall Street Journal,
in 2013, would name Obama--
I call him, for this
talk, the ELSI Presidency.
She calls him the Big
Data Presidency, but not
because of the PMI.
She calls him the
Big Data Presidency
because she's writing
here about the NSA
and about the surveillance
infrastructure
that the Obama
administration-- another thing
distinctive to science and
technology in the Obama
administration-- expanded more
than any administration prior.
So all of us in the
Precision Medicine Initiative
are happening at a
time where we have
a ratcheting up in
public discourse
of conversation about big data,
more generally, and concerns
about surveillance, both on
the part of a cyber security
infrastructure and on the
part of private companies.
Such that, this
is from Stat News,
by 2017, it's the case that
we're being told that in order
to advance medicine's future--
and this is an article on
how the NIH is endeavoring
through all of us to win the
trust of communities who had
been mistreated in the past--
as a central challenge to
the work that they're doing.
So this is from that
2015 announcement
of the first launch of
the PMI, in the east room
at the White House.
President Obama pictured there
with Francis Collins, director
of the NIH, and Harold
Varmus, who, for a time,
was co-chair with
John Holdren and Eric
Lander of the President
Council of Advisors
on Science and Technology.
So this is a moment of
possibility and aspiration,
as I said.
But it also takes a few years.
This is 2015.
It's not really until
late 2017, early 2018,
that the real enrollment
for all of us begins.
And I should say that
my university, Columbia,
working with Mt.
Sinai and some other
institutions in New York City,
is one of the enrollment centers
for the Precision Medicine
Initiative.
So what's also
happening in big data?
So this is how Wired chooses
to cover the launch of the NIH
All of Us enrollment.
The first line here, from
this piece from May of 2018,
is about Cambridge Analytica,
and talks about the challenges
that the NIH and all of us
will face with the Precision
Medicine Initiative, in which
the public is increasingly
concerned about data.
Washington Post, "NIH
seeks health data
of 1 million people,
with genetic privacy
suddenly an issue,"
again, from May of 2018.
So I want to suggest here
that, as I describe in my book
that Dean Brown-Nagin
so generously described,
The Social Life of DNA,
part of what is happening
with regards to the
Precision Medicine Initiative
is that the ways in which
ideas about data and DNA
are elaborated in
one social site
actually affect how people think
about them in other places.
So it is the case, for example,
that people that I interviewed
about direct to consumer
ancestry testing
would often reference things
like the use of genetics
in the criminal justice system.
In this case, to exonerate a
man who'd been wrongly in prison
for 25 years, who was
exonerated through the work
of the Innocence Project,
which has freed just
under 300 people over more
than a decade of work.
Also happening, particularly
in the new presidential
administration, are debates
about whether DNA testing
and DNA analysis should be used
to reunite immigrant families
in a political moment in
which anti-immigrant fears
and anti-immigrant sentiment
in the United States
is pronounced.
As well as the use of databases
by the criminal justice
system without warrants and
other legal regulations being
met.
So part of what
I want to suggest
is that as we move from Obama,
the ELSI President, the Big
Data President, and also the
Black President, who I think
holds a particular place and
can say particular things
about how genetics
might be misused,
how data might be misused.
But also in the way that
was true of his presidency,
allow people to trust him
as his person and a person.
Much of this is lost in
the Trump presidency.
I think that few could imagine
launching a Precision Medicine
Initiative, I think, in the same
way under a Trump presidency.
But here we have an initiative
that is moving forward.
And it's moving forward to
an enrollment stage at a time
where there are legitimate
concerns about genetics
and about data, more generally.
So the ELSI frame--
that becomes the frame, in part,
for federal science, I argue,
in the Obama administration--
has faced lots of criticism.
As early as 2003, the science
and technology studies scholar,
Landon Winter,
who was testifying
at a committee on the
ELSI of nanotechnology,
would say, "there is a tendency
for those to conduct research
about the ethical dimensions
of emerging technology
to gravitate towards
the more comfortable
even trivial questions involved,
avoiding issues that might
become a focus of conflict.
People in bioethics
rarely say no."
And one might say the same
of the Obama Administration's
approach to its ethical framing.
So while it did give voice
to mistreatment of the past,
it did do a kind
of performance that
allowed people,
if they wanted to,
overcome the skepticism
that they had.
They were never meant to be
engagements, conversations,
performances, public
events that were
intended for people to say no.
It was always the case that
the moonshots would proceed.
It was always the case
that the moonshots
would be funded
almost exclusively
through federal
appropriation, in this case.
Because Obama's funding
was blocked in other ways.
But they also
knew, as an entity,
as an organization, that they
had to have a flight plan.
That there had to be some public
performance, some public voice
to ethical guardrails
and concerns.
We can hope that
as we move forward
in thinking about the
ethical turn more generally
in US culture with regards to
data ethics, computer science
ethics, genetics and
ethics, and the like,
that we might hark
back to a time in 1990,
where we imagined that an
ethical orientation to science
and technology could
be broad and capacious.
It could include
unprotected data banks.
It could include a
genetic underclass
now well in formation, law
enforcement agencies, as well.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm Nick Patterson I'm a
geneticist and I've worked
extensively on African-American
medical genetics.
And I just wanted to tell
you a small incident, which
I think is revealing about the
difficulties of interacting
with scientific research
and law enforcement.
I was involved in a
cardiovascular study
on African-Americans.
We were seeking genetic
links to heart disease
in the African-American
community.
This is something called
the Jackson Heart Study.
And it was centered
in Mississippi.
The response we got from the
African-American community
down there was much
worse than we thought.
We got fewer people signed up.
And the key thing was
that many, many members
of the African-American
community
said, if I give
you my DNA, will it
be available to law enforcement?
And the answer is, under
subpoena, absolutely, yes.
Thank you very much.
We don't want to know anymore.
So that's a real difficulty.
You have an ethics community
in the White House.
You have law enforcement
organizations, sometimes
at state level, who aren't
the least interested
in what the White
House is saying.
And the whole thing interacts
in very complex ways,
often not very advantageous.
I don't really
have a model, here.
But I wonder if you have.
- Well, I guess one
thing I would say
is that it needs to be
OK for people to say no.
So I think that we need to be
able to have a conversation
in which folks should say no.
And there's not a sense of
entitlement to people's DNA
information is one
thing I would offer.
I thought, actually,
you were going
to say something
about the Tuskegee
Experiment or the Holocaust.
These are the kinds
of, particularly
in the social science
literature and medicine,
stories that come up more
often about people's refusal
or skepticism, about
African-Americans
in particular, about
participating in such studies.
But the headlines that
I ended with, certainly,
when I first started
working with people
around contemporary genetics
issues, post-human genome
genetics, conversations I would
have with African-Americans--
it was certainly the case
that the criminal justice
system was mentioned.
But there were all sorts of
other fears that people had,
as well.
I think as we continue to
have these high profile
cases in which not only
are folks exonerated--
and we should say that something
like the Innocence Project
only makes sense in a
society in which you
incarcerate 2.3 million people,
many of them without cause.
But as these cases come to light
of surreptitious DNA collection
by criminal justice authorities,
the use of what people thought
were citizen science databases
that they were participating in
with other geneticists to learn
more about their families,
being used, again, without
subpoena, without a warrant
by the criminal justice
system, that it's only
going to get more challenging.
So I would say to
you that if you
were to go ahead
and do that now,
in the face of two summers,
now, of these stories about how
pernicious the criminal
justice authorities have been
and their use of
these open databases,
that your yield
would be less, still.
Thanks for your comment.
- Doctor Nelson,
that was fantastic.
Thank you.
- Thank you.
- I'm thinking with
my capture hat on.
- Yes.
- And I am wondering--
and I'm just I'm looking
forward to reading the book
and learning more--
what was the role of commercial
corporate enterprises
in this process?
And once upon a time,
recognizing as I say this--
and I'll just leave
the answer to you--
we would have thought, well,
the drug companies or biopharma.
But in the world that
you're describing,
as you know undoubtedly
better than I do,
it's these networks of capital,
and science, and technology.
Venture capital funds,
hedge funds, Silicon Valley,
which is the new biggest
player in health care,
in combination with these.
And so just an
open ended question
that I'd just love
to know more about
is, what were the pressure
points that you've
seen in the Obama
administration,
including in some
of these groups,
Holdren's groups, and
others for what you might
call industrial interests?
- Yes.
You won't be surprised to hear
that the industrial interests
were significant.
Yes, right.
But distinctive in that many of
them were for Silicon Valley.
So you had, I think, instead
of having the K Street lobby
situation, you had people who--
in some cases,
young entrepreneurs
or VCs from Silicon
Valley-- were really
engaging with the federal
government for the first time.
And engagement, as opposed to
we just want to disrupt it.
It was actually, we will go.
We will take meetings
and the like.
So that was
certainly part of it.
Part of what I've heard a lot in
the conversations with staffers
is that you'll recall that
the Obama Administration did
a lot of commitments.
So My Brother's
Keeper, for example,
would be one of
these commitments.
Which partly because the Obama
administration was really
blocked in getting funding for
things through the legislature,
they were, I think,
made to do more and be
more creative in these
commercial partnerships.
And so they borrowed
this commitment model
from the Clinton Foundation.
It's the Clinton
Global Foundation--
it's the private public
commitments model.
And do quite a lot of that.
But it becomes not so
much a free market,
ideological commitment.
But I think there's
that, of course.
But also, I think
this happens a lot.
The strategy that
they're left with,
given that they can't get money
out of the legislature, right?
Given that in the first
few hours after Obama
is first president, Mitch
McConnell is basically like,
we will frustrate anything
you try to do, forever.
And that has implications
for what they're able to do
and who they must
partner with in the work
that they do in science.
Also this is a total nerdy,
Daniel Carpenter thing.
Given what I've learned
from you about bureaucracy,
but it also had implications
for how they did their work.
So they couldn't appoint people.
Because you couldn't
get any appropriations
lines to appoint people.
So the Innovation Fellows,
which I was just like,
it was so amazing.
The first interviews I was
doing, I was just like,
oh, it was so amazing.
You guys did this
Innovation Fellows.
And someone sort of
said to me flatly,
you know why we had to do that?
It's because we
didn't have any budget
lines to make any appointments.
But you can appoint a Fellow.
The president can
appoint Fellows all day
and try to figure out how to
get funding to support them.
So it's partly not a
new story about capture.
But it's partly
about what happens
in a presidential administration
with a deeply recalcitrant
legislative branch, and how
they try to work around that.
- Hi, thank you for this.
I wanted to ask you
a little bit more
about how the current public
conversation around the ethics
of big data is impacting the
way that this ethical framing is
taking form.
Because if I think back to the
early days of the Human Genome
Project and the emergence
of the ELSI agenda,
you can see pretty clearly
how it is that the HIV AIDS
epidemic that was taking place
in that historical moment,
that impacted what people
were thinking about in terms
of ethical issues.
But here, the connection
seems a little bit looser
to me, in that you have a lot of
public conversation about data
privacy, and the
right to privacy.
While at the same time, you
have a very pro information
bias in what's happening in the
Precision Medicine Initiative.
That's about access to
research as a good, right?
So I'm wondering if you
can just draw those links
a little bit closer
about how it is
that the important
ethical conversations
of this historical moment are
shaping what's going on today?
- Yeah, thank you for that.
That's a really great question.
And I'm not sure that I'll
have a totally complete answer,
but I'll endeavor one.
So I think we see it a
little bit in the quote
that I pulled about Obama
saying, if that's my DNA,
then that's me.
And you see it as well in that
document of privacy and trust
principles.
So it's very much about putting
the individual consumer,
as data point, data
supplier, in the driver's
seat of making decisions
about privacy and access
to their data.
Even as we know that that's
not the legal standard,
it very much gives voice
to that as a sort of ethos
and as an ideal.
And so the ethical
complication is that the ELSI--
and the Paul Rabinow
slide that I put up
suggests this, as well--
as it's designed, is
really downstream.
So you build the technology.
And then you decide or
have some conversation
about what happens with it.
As opposed to a
project like PMI,
which would really require a
more anticipatory, or upstream,
or midstream approach.
Something where you're
asking questions
as it's happening and engaging
individuals in communities with
regards to how they
think about it.
So there is a mismatch.
I think you're right.
And why the dots
don't connect is
that I think what we expect
for ethics in this moment
are different from the formative
ELSI moment, with regards
to ELSI information, as opposed
to being solely downstream,
after the project
is all but baked.
What Rabinow uses as a
distinction that's very useful
is that he distinguishes--
I should say
Rabinow and Bennet--
between what he calls
cooperation and collaboration.
And so for him,
with the ELSI work,
cooperation is like
the bioethicists,
the social scientists
are supposed
to be here working on
a parallel track that
does not intersect at all any
of the science or miss any of it
up.
It's really like
get out of here.
And what they were
imagining when
they got involved in the
Systems Bio ELSI Project
was collaboration-- that
there would be conversations
early on.
What does it mean
that we don't yet
have laws that allow people to
say that their data is theirs?
How are we going to
think about that?
What are we going
to do about that?
And that was really kind of
forestalled in the project.
So I think you're right.
The dots don't connect, because
there's a new, larger ethical
conversation that is emerging.
And I was talking
to students today
in the Radcliffe Student
Program about the ethical turn
has not only come
to federal science.
It's come to how we think
about society, more generally.
We actually think the
ethics of data ethics
is a kind of panacea
for everything.
And obviously, that's quite
dangerous and obviously not
true.
But it also means that we don't
use words like discrimination,
justice, injustice.
Ethics fills that
space, as well.
So that's another
backdrop that makes,
I think, the ELSI piece a bit
both inadequate for this moment
and a little murky.
- Thank you for that.
- Hi.
- I'm a biologist and chemist
in the chemistry grad program
at MIT.
And as biologists, we get data.
And then it's up to us
to decide what it means.
And there's a couple
of places where
I'm a little bit
concerned about that.
If the milk chugging
challenge is any indication,
white supremacists will
take meaningless biological
distinctions and
twist and turn them
upside down until they say
something that justifies
their bigoted bullshit.
And then in a more
subtle distinction,
biologists tend to take
doctors' word for it
in terms of what is a
pathology, despite the known
history, in which
being gay and trans
used to be listed in
the DM5 as disorders.
And now, we know how
ridiculous that is.
And biologists will
continue to do GWA studies,
trying to figure out which
genes cause the autism
disease without ever questioning
whether autism is actually
a disorder.
And the vast majority
of autistic people
don't want to be cured.
They want to be accepted.
So I'm wondering.
So let's say that we get
all of these very broad,
genetic studies to happen.
People are willing to
give up their data.
Was their thought in
the Obama administration
about how to keep that data
from being misinterpreted
and misused?
- Not at all.
Your opening sentence was I'm
a biologist and a chemist.
And we use this data.
And we don't say what it means.
But of course, you
do say what it means.
- I said it is up
to us to figure out.
- It is up to you.
And you are engaged,
particularly if you're
talking about human genetics,
and about human disease,
and a practice of creating
classifications and categories
that are racialized.
And so then when the white
supremacists take up,
in another way,
ways that we create
algorithms and meanings out of
data, we can be mad about it.
Because it's disgusting.
But we also can't
be mad about it.
Because it is another
practice of classification
and categorization.
That is, I think, part of
what science does at its best
and at its worst.
So there's no surprises there.
And I think the
cluster of things
that you raised are about
the issue of the politics
and power of classification
and how to think about that.
And I think scientists have
to be upfront about that.
That's part of what the work
is and that these categories
travel in the world.
A lot of my work has
been how lay people
and sometimes not lay
people really take up
scientific categories
and use them
for all sorts of political work.
And the literature on
not only Amy Harman's
reporting in The Times, but
the social science literature,
Aaron Pinovsky and
Joan Donovan's work
on how white nationalists
interpret genetic ancestry
testing--
sorry to say, I guess,
as a social scientist,
happy to say that the mechanisms
that I describe in my work
with African-Americans
are the same mechanisms.
That's the same categories
or those same schema
in which ways people are
making sense of what it means.
It's negation, magical
thinking, acceptance, sort
of drilling down into the data.
They're the same kind of
gestures, unfortunately.
- Thank you for
a wonderful talk.
Janet Rich-Edwards.
I'm an epidemiologist here,
at Harvard, and this year,
a Radcliffe Fellow.
- Great.
- And my question is about--
this feels very internally
domestic facing for the US.
- Sure.
- And I'm curious about,
during this administration,
attempts to coordinate, debate,
discuss with other countries.
And this feels
like it's becoming
even more relevant, for example,
with the recent gene editing
of human embryos from China.
I'm just curious about how
the administration thought
about that.
- I don't know.
I haven't actually
looked into that.
If there are others who know
more about it, do let me know.
The thing about
federal science is
it's so nation state obsessed.
Even one of the
examples Jennifer--
of how the Personalized Genomics
Act of 2006 to 2007 sort of
uses the phrase of
securing genomic medicine
for all Americans.
It's very much kind of a
nationalist, sovereign project
around genetics, even as we
understand these things to sort
be global and planetary in
their scale and implications.
I certainly wondered, actually,
what an Obama administration
would have said about lots
of contemporary controversies
in science, even around the
issue of Cambridge Analytica,
things that lack a
regulation around big tech,
and certainly with
the gene editing.
It's hard to know.
I'll say this.
I was a witness,
or gave testimony,
or had a conversation with
some colleagues at the National
Academies who did an NAS
report on gene editing,
and germline editing, and trying
to distinguish between those
and what might be done.
And even people in
that room, who I think
knew better and think
about these things
on the global scale, in
structure of the NHS,
it's a kind of
national conversation.
So there would be gestures such
as if we changed the germ line,
we are changing all
of human population.
But somehow, that then
could be captured back
into a conversation about
science in the United States.
So I think in these
kind of federal bodies,
we do a disservice to
what are planetary issues,
as you suggest.
- Thank you so
much for this talk.
I think I'm very
persuaded by the question
of ethical framing or
the way that you're
describing ethical framing.
I wonder whether
you could juxtapose
this kind of ethical
framing around medicine,
and technology, and
the technologies
related to this
particular program,
particularly with the Obama
administration's drone program.
Because in the Obama
administration,
in 2012, they describe drones
as, specifically, ethical.
That was the language
that they used.
- Yeah.
- And so it seems
to me that there
is a very interesting
politics around ethics that's
part of Obama, which I would
love to hear just how you think
about the specificity,
here, but also
juxtaposing those
different ethical contexts.
- Don't leave.
Because I'd actually like to
have a back and forth one about
this.
Something that just
happened around drones,
I've thought about this.
And I think when I'm
writing up the AI piece,
I will write about drones.
But the news last week is
that the Trump Administration
is no longer going to
count drone deaths.
So that was a moment
where I thought,
was it ethical to
count drone deaths?
Do we wish that we had an
Obama Administration that
thought that they were doing
some sort of ethical exercise
in the fact that
they were offering
some sort of public
accountability
to automated death squads?
And so I don't have, I
think, an easy answer.
to that.
Certainly, that's not ethical.
And I'm not even sure.
I use framing, and
I use performance,
because I don't want to
suggest in a normative sense
that this is ethical.
But that we have reached
a moment as a society
that if you want to advance
certain scientific endeavors,
post Hiroshima, post name your--
Jacques Ranciere has this
essay on the ethical turn
in politics.
And for him, it's a temporality
that's post atrocity.
It's any post atrocity turn then
becomes the ethical politics.
So I would want to
forestall the use of ethical
as a normative claim,
but understand it
as a necessary narrative
of legitimation
or a necessary practice
of legitimation.
- I think it's exactly correct.
I just think there's
something interesting.
Because I think he puts
himself very forward
in this kind of ethical framing.
You didn't see
Obama that much when
it came to the drone warfare.
- That's right.
No, I think that's-- well--
- Well--
- --yes and no.
He wouldn't be having a
summit on a stage talking
about the misdeeds of the past.
But there are some conversations
with him about the drone stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Join me in thanking
Doctor Nelson
for that wonderful lecture.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]